For SEAC tea, liquid concentrate protocol, I understand to use one table spooned hot water
sipped over 15 minutes. I usually use eight ounces of water. What if I use room temperature
of water? Also, one of the consequences of drinking it all at once, especially if I forget
to sip it over 15 minutes or I'm in a hurry. Yeah, this is a hard one because that was just
a recommended protocol that that was always recommended for SEAC and it was typically you sip it
over 15 to 30 minutes. You make a tea out of it. Is there benefit to that? I don't know. I don't
really know. I've had patients over the years that they mix it in their smoothies. It's like
I don't think that any ill consequences. I mean, I don't think it, you know, didn't work any last.
You know, they're just herbs and just because they were mixed in a tea at one point in time,
doesn't mean you have to do it that same way all the time. You know, it's like the old story of,
you know, the lady who cuts off the end of the roast before she puts it in the pan,
before she puts it in the oven and her husband said, why do you do that? She said, well,
because mom always did it. We'll call her and ask her. She called her mom and said, why do you always
cut the end off the roast before you put it in the pan before you put it in the oven? She said,
I don't know. Grandma used to always do that. So she called grandma. Why do you always cut the
end off the roast before you put it in the pan before you put it in the oven? Grandma said,
because the pan was too small. So sometimes there's not always a good reason for why it's done.
I just try to logically think through it and I don't think that doing it the way you're doing it
is necessarily going to cause any different effects of it. Sometimes there's a physiological reason for it
and I can kind of rationalize through that and some of these things and sometimes I can't figure out
any physiological difference. Certainly taking any nutrient over a longer period of time, you're going to
have maybe better absorption of it and if you take a nutrient and break it down into three doses
over the day, you know, we've talked about every nutrient in your body has a half-life,
meaning that if I take everything, you know, we'll just take it six o'clock in the morning,
there's good chance that six o'clock at night. I don't have a whole lot of that nutrient-circulated
web bloodstream. So he was spreading out the dosage definitely has physiological benefit.
I don't want to seep it at over 15 minutes versus gophe to dial it has much.